she stopped they'll know the suit is
missing a small voice said in the back
of her mind
they'll know where you've gone they'll
come after you her breath was heavy and
fast her heart racing
the thing she'd been trying not to think
for the last hours came to the front of
her mind like an old friend
fewer than 50 meters it isn't far you
can make it
she closed the locker the inner door of
the airlock was open now
she launched herself toward it forcing
herself to pant to hyper-oxygenate she
couldn't tell if the dizziness she
felt was from too much oxygen or a kind
of existential vertigo
she was really gonna do this naked in
the void 50 meters in hard vacuum
maybe less maybe it was possible she
couldn't depressurize
first the long seconds matching the
airlock to the outer nothingness would
take more time than she had
she'd have to blow it out full pressure
to nothing in a fraction of a second
if she held her breath it would pop her
lungs she would have to blow herself
empty first
let the void into her all around her
heart even if it worked it would do her
damage
she could handle that hey guys pete here
this is my breakdown of the expanse
season 5
episode 7. naomi's time on the pella has
come to an
end the fears that brought her there
proved warranted
even though she was able to make some
progress in connecting with philip
his father's grip the indoctrination his
wanting to please this larger-than-life
figure that was his dad
things were stacked against her and it
was all too much for her to go up
against
and now she has to say goodbye that's
where the title comes from the belter
word for goodbye
and before we talk about everything that
happened in this episode
i gotta give you a spoiler warning if
you're not caught up with the expanse tv
show through
season 5 episode 7 then this video won't
be for you
as someone who's read all the books i
will be referring to those
but i won't be talking about any future
spoilers from them
with that out of the way let's get
started the episode opens with a
flashback we see naomi thinking about
her life with philip when he was a baby
before the first time she had to say
goodbye we see that they look happy and
we know this is before the
and gomorrah which we'll talk about in a
minute in his room philip's looking at
his hand terminal reading about the
events of the slow zone
and what happened on the behemoth marco
comes in he wants to know what he's
doing
philip quickly clears the screen and
talks about palace and marco talks about
that
talking about their humble beginnings
how they started there with nothing and
look at us now basically
as they're talking we get some insight
into his manipulation
at one point philip says i want you to
be proud of me and marco responds i know
rather than i am he asked his son if he
can use the chet's mocha which naomi
gave him
because it's just an old junker and it
doesn't really help the fleet
he says i know you've been spending some
time with your mother and he presents
himself as caring by saying i didn't
know if the ship had some kind of
sentimental value for you
we see how philip is 100 on board to
please his father
he says it means nothing and the look on
his face says i'll do whatever you need
me to do
that cuts to marco going to see naomi
and i think it stands out here you see
he approaches her with caution because
he knows that she understands the way he
operates
a lot better than philip would he says
he was actually impressed that she had
the nerve to try and kill him
he brings up that it's been a long time
since it's just been the two of them
together
trying to get her to think about those
good times before everything went wrong
and when this doesn't work when she
starts to push back he says he just
wants to know why she came back
into philip's life right now they go
back and forth where she says he forced
her out of philip's life and he says he
only hit him away because he wanted to
make her come back to him
he never would have used her code to
destroy the august and gomorrah if he
knew what would have happened between
them she knows he isn't being sincere
and she says that beyond regret the
other thing she felt was relief because
the pain of losing philip was not as
horrible as having to stay with him
and you can see that they're playing a
game they both have things that they can
hold over the
other person and they're pushing each
other's buttons marco has the clear
advantage in the situation
since she's on his ship and what's
really interesting
is that his last statement is what they
both want but for the other person
naomi wants to show philip who marco
really is
and marco says that he wants to show
phillip who she really is
they also talk about why he hasn't
killed her yet which is interesting
considering we know that he had already
tried to
when he told sin and philip to space her
so that underlines for us
what she already knows and that's that
you can't trust anything marcos says
when the conversation ends he lets her
roam freely on the ship
she goes looking for phillip and finds
his room empty that gives her a chance
to look around his room and get an idea
of who he is
he comes in they have a mother and son
conversation where she says i miss so
much of your life
he tells her he's been reading about
what happened and what she did at the
ring gates and how she saved a lot of
belter's lives
she tells him what happened with the
august and gemara and finds out that he
already knows about it and thinks it was
a great victory
and we see that he's reluctant to change
his mind about being a fighter
it's what he's been taught it's his
identity it's what he strives to be
he wants to be strong he wants to be a
fighter and most of all he wants his
father's approval
there's a touching exchange where he
lets his guard down and asks why she
left him
she tells him she looked everywhere she
had to accept that she couldn't find him
and she tells him the story about how
she almost committed suicide by throwing
herself
out an airlock in the process of doing
that she realized that pushing the
button wouldn't change anything
that her only choice was walking away
and she implies that his only choice is
to walk away as well
so everything on the pellet is pretty
emotionally charged
things are a little more straightforward
on the rostanante holden
and bull are trying to locate the zamaya
the question comes up about
if they do find them what are they going
to do with the proto molecule and holden
says that they're going to destroy it
everybody seems to agree this is the
best idea and we learned that even
though we just met bull on taiko this
season
he's actually been working for fred
johnson for a long time
this means he knows a lot about fred and
he also knows a lot about holden
based on their association holden tells
him that he never really trusted fred
and bull already knows this in my
preview video i mentioned that monica
might turn out to be important in this
part of the story and it caught my
attention that she said that she was
reaching out to a source on series with
connections to the inaros faction
she says if there's any chatter about a
handoff she'll hear about it definitely
something to keep in mind considering
how things turn out
holden gets a message from alex and
finds out that he's burning towards
tycho
they figure out that he's close because
of the short delay on the message
on the razorback we see that avasarala
is in contact with them
she says that jupiter and saturn fleets
are pulling back to guard the inner
planets
and that they've sent her the details
about the ships that marco has in the
free navy
they also send these ship profiles to
holden he sees the nine different mars
warships and he notices the chetsamoka
of course he wants to go and help naomi
but he realizes that the proto-molecule
sample is their priority
he asks alex and bobby to watch the
chetsamoka and tells them that marco
kidnapped naomi
alex promises that they won't lose the
ship later holden and monica talk he
comes clean about their sample and about
how naomi gave it to fred in the first
place
saying that she had good reasons to do
so monica points out that there must be
someone high up in the martian military
helping marco get these ships
seeing weapons and things like that in
the black market is one thing but
getting ships is way more complicated
and she's convinced that the martians
either have
his same political goals or they're
getting something else in return
and she thinks it's probably cortazar in
the protomolecule sample
this seems like a really likely
explanation and when she asks why
marco took naomi holden tells her about
philip and that whole situation
and he also says he got a message from
her but they get interrupted before we
can find out what was in it
the rossi has located the zamaya and we
get this really kick-ass battle scene
when it tries to defend itself
it fires a bunch of torpedoes and we get
to see the rossi do this
incredible roll with the pdcs going in
all directions taking out all of the
torpedoes
they're able to do that with minimal
damage they lose one of the pdcs
and then holden decides that he wants to
board the ship rather than just
destroying it bull and monica both
object
but holden insists that they have to try
to get answers from the crew
and uses the railgun to disable it
they're planning to use their drones to
board first in case it's booby trap but
the zemaya self-destructs before they
can
now you might be wondering what about
the proto-molecule if they blew up the
ship did they also blow up the sample
my guess is probably not it's possible
that they could have passed it off
earlier but then also if you look
closely when the torpedoes are firing
off the last one looks different
its exhaust is blue like it has an
epstein drive and it seems to break in
the other direction away from the
rasanante
and i think there's a pretty good chance
that it might have been carrying the
sample
to rewind a little bit we saw sin
working on the chatsumoka while it was
docked with the pella
when he comes back we see him run into
naomi in the mess
and in a heartfelt exchange he tells her
he followed her when she went to the
airlock to try to kill herself
and he breaks down telling her that he
actually helped marco hide philip from
her back in the day
he apologizes and explains that he
thought it would bring them all back
together he tells naomi he loved her and
he tells her that he loved
all of them he loves their whole crew
their whole family
and when he saw her on palace earlier in
the season he thought it was his chance
to make things right
she says that it could be and she asks
him to help her now
on the bridge we see that marco was
following what was happening with the
zamaya he says that they have their
instructions and they know what to do
sin comes in and marco blames him and
phillip saying that it's their fault
that everything's going wrong and sin
pleads with him to let naomi leave
and marco doesn't want to hear anything
about it he says she's trying to take
her son away from him
away from them and he's never going to
let her leave and if sin doesn't like it
then he can't
we see marco looking at charts on a
monitor we see that he's looking at
where the unn
and mcrn ships are in the system he's
looking at the soul gate we notice
there are two u.n ships and one from
mars
that are kind of guarding it philip
comes in and he tells his father that he
wants to take command of one of their
ships that he wants people to know who
he
is and marco seizes on this opportunity
to tear his son
down he points out all the things that
have gone wrong and puts it on philip
personally
saying your weakness nearly undid
everything we fought for
that's who you are he says that the
belters are chanting his name and that
basically philip's nothing without him
he's his heir and someday he will lead
the belt but not until after marco's
gone
and it shows us how marco thinks of
himself how he thinks of this situation
how everything that goes right is
because he planned it so well
and everything that's gone wrong has
happened because
someone else wasn't up to the task that
he gave them
serge comes to naomi in her room and
tells her that
marco wants to see her and we see where
all of this character stuff and all this
setup was heading he tells her that he
has decided to let her leave
but not until after he uses her ship to
lure in the rasanante
and kill her family once she's seen that
he'll put her on the float he says that
philip inspired the idea
and in a really difficult scene we see
her reach out to him
him throwing everything back in her face
insulting her
literally hitting her and just doing his
father's bidding
wanting to be known as the person who
took out the rasanante
marco frames this and everything we saw
happen that was real between naomi and
philip between mother and son as her
trying to betray him he basically
undermines her credibility
and this is the culmination of his
attempt to show
philip who his mother really is as
viewers we know that she was being
sincere and she was trying to help her
son
but we see that he's in so deep here and
that his father's so good at using that
to his advantage
at this point naomi knows that there's
nothing she can do
except walk away and she's left to
follow her own advice
the problem is is that she has to make
it look like she's going to commit
suicide
because if she took a vac suit the
ship's systems will know it's missing
and then they would come looking for her
that's what she was contemplating in the
excerpt i read at the very beginning of
the video
the downside of this is that her son is
gonna think that what he did
caused her to commit suicide so it's a
really impossible situation
and because the ships are separating and
the chet smoke is leaving and this is
her last chance
she makes the difficult decision and she
goes to the airlock
sin realizes this when he looks for her
on the monitors
and he tries to intervene because he
thinks she's trying to kill herself as
well
he inserts himself into the impossible
situation
further complicating things for her and
because this is the last chance she has
he becomes a sacrifice we see that she's
holding some of that hyper-oxygenated
blood
like what we saw them give monica when
they saved her in the shipping container
earlier in the season
we see that she was breathing heavy to
oxygenate her own blood
she exhales as the door opens because if
she hadn't the air inside her lungs
would have expanded with the loss of
pressure
that could have killed her and that's
probably what killed sin
i'm not an expert on these things but i
did look up what happens to a human body
in hard vacuum when i first read the
book and it seems like the authors did
their homework
when she launches herself she would have
something like 15 seconds until she
would lose consciousness
and that's where the hyper-oxygenated
blood comes in i thought it was a great
touch how you notice the red color
around the edges of her vision
as she reaches the limit she jabs
herself with the injector and is able to
make it to the chatsumoka
but while things look pretty peaceful
out there her body is being put through
the ringer she has no protection from
the sun or solar radiation so her skin
would be getting an intense sunburn
without external pressure the water in
her body would be vaporizing
and that causes the noticeable swelling
so it should go without saying that even
though she makes it inside the other
ship
she'll be feeling the effects of this
for some time she's definitely
injured we'll have to wait until next
week to see what happens when she makes
it inside but we do know that the chet's
mocha has been put on autopilot with the
intention of drawing the rasanante to it
alex and bobby could find it and they
would be able to tell holden where it is
but they'll all be falling into the trap
that marco has set for them
and that is where the episode ends so
really just a fantastic episode i was
curious as to how this would play out
because so much of it happens in naomi's
head all the planning
her getting ready her making the
decision that she has to do that
the show did a pretty good job of
setting things up in a way that it made
sense when she's standing there
her interactions with philip marcos
strategically
and manipulatively setting things up so
there's no way that she can get through
to him
she may have been successful in planting
some seeds there but there was no way
that she was going to get him to walk
away from his father
in the current situation so the writing
was good it made it work
and the acting from all of them really
took things up to the next level
it's a tragic situation for everyone
involved and we see how marco uses
everything he can
to shift things to his advantage it's an
episode that was really heavy on
character stuff
i kept wanting to cut things out to make
it shorter when i was writing the recap
but everything was so important
amos had his episode where he really got
deep into where his character is going
seeing him realize that he needs to get
back with his crew
and i'm glad that they took as much care
here with naomi
watching her putting herself through
that physically making the decision to
leave her son behind
knowing that he'll think he's partly
responsible for what happened
all so that she can try to save her
family on the rosanante
it's a defining moment for the character
it was crafted so well
and it was so gripping to watch they
really did pull it off
we didn't get any amos and clarissa or
any drummer at all in this episode
but overall i thought the balancing here
worked better
now that all the stories are kind of
headed in the same direction
just a brief scene with abasarala
talking with alex and bobby but in that
we know that she's finding out more
about what's going on
that she knows the free navies flying
around in martian ships
and even though we only see a little bit
of alex and bobby the scene where she
finds the bullet is fun
and through the communications with
holden we know they're all going to end
up in the same place soon
holden's got himself a temporary crew
and i like the way these characters work
together
they're giving bull some depth monica
seems to be putting together an
idea of what the big picture might be
holden not pulling the trigger
not following through with destroying
the proto-molecule right away
makes you wonder what he was thinking
but it is possible that that was more
about naomi in trying to find her like
he said
and the battle scene was just a lot of
fun to watch so i like where we're at
i'm excited to think about where things
are going and in a few days i'll put up
another video where we'll talk about
that and i think this is a good place to
leave things
because i really want to hear what you
guys think in the comments so let me
know what you're thinking
pretty emotional episode we're getting
some great development of the crew
members on their own
and they're all feeling that separation
and trying to get back together
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
let me know what you're thinking and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon